es una decisión sin precedentes que se
da un día después de que un juez en eeuu
le ha dado luz verde para este proceso
civil en contra del duque de york o por
supuesto abuso sexual hecho que el duque
ha negado en repetidas ocasiones de esta
manera la reina isabel que es la jefe de
estado en este país está tratando de
proteger la integridad y el futuro de la
monarquía salpicado por este escándalo
de su segundo hijo también la familia
real quiere tomar distancia de andrés
justo en este año cuando se celebrarán
los 70 años del reinado de isabel de
isabel segunda y también se ha conocido
que organizaciones de militares le
habían pedido a la propia reina despojar
a su hijo andrés de los títulos
militares porque no querían estar
implicados con el príncipe de ninguna
manera el comunicado del palacio de
buckingham bien escueto esta noche es
bien evidente en lo que será el futuro
de andrés a partir de ahora el duque de
york seguirá sin asumir tareas públicas